and here's what's going to happen with
the economy if we go through it so
interest rates right now 5.7
which means you would have bought a
house eight months ago your rates would
have been three percent two and a half
percent right now it's 5.7 percent
here's what people don't realize
if you go back from today
let's just say go all the way back to
1970
do you know from 2008
prior from 2008 and prior like 1970 to
2008 do you know the interest rates have
never been at 5.7 percent it's always
about 5.7
let me say this one more time from 08
and prior to 70 rates have always been
six and a half seven and a half eight
and a half nine and a half
in 81 under carter was at 18 and a half
percent okay but that was pretty bad now
let's go worst case scenario let's go
best case scenario and you decide where
you want to manage your level of risk
tolerance
so let's let's move on to some of the
some of your sort of nuts and bolts
stuff because we talked a little bit
about economy uh a couple weeks ago you
had a video out that i saw where i think
you said but correct me if i'm wrong
that you said that we would officially
or they would officially announce a
recession i think you said by july 15th
it seems to me they've already kind of
admitted it yellen has sort of you
probably saw the video where she said
well we're probably in one but we're
hopeful and then they all kind of admit
it well i i guess a do you think we are
i mean i think technically we are in a
recession but do you think they will
admit it and how do you feel about july
15th middle of the month i mean are we
there
i think july 1st was the first day of
recession
i think the numbers on gdp has got to
come out july 28th and we'll find out if
it's two quarters of the economy
declining and then it'll become official
with some economists will say that uh
now cnn i don't know if you saw the
article last week by cnn saying you know
some experts are saying uh uh we're in
recession but why is it that it's eight
white economists that are saying we're
in recession
yeah yeah
yeah when it comes down to recession
nobody cares what color you are
and they said these economists are not
diverse enough you know there's no
african-american economist in america
the african-american population is 13
but only three percent are economists
you know and this percent is this but
that percent is this and i said look you
know in
america
um 24 of the population is hispanic
but in the nba it's only one hispanic
player what a racist organization the
nba is why don't you guys go a little
bit more diverse and have hire some
hispanics there is no iranian basketball
i'm offended that you guys don't have
any iranian basketball players in the
nba so you hear comments like this
people are making to get people
distracted from the fact that we're in
recession
it's what's happening now the question
becomes
how ugly can it get
and
you know how many people will be
prepared for and what policies the
current administration will come my
hopes is they don't do one thing and the
one thing i hope they don't do because
it's going to happen when lehman
brothers when aig when all these
companies are going through what they
went through on 07.0809 when we remember
what happened there
those stories are going to come up when
some banks are not going to make it
you're going to hear some stories of
some of these companies that are
multi-multi-billion auto companies
they're not going to make it and they're
going to need to be
bailed out i just hope dave they don't
go the bailout model because if they go
to bailout model what the bailout model
does is it just delays the headache for
10 more years it delays the headache for
10 more years it keeps delaying it
versus let's just go through it and
here's what's going to happen with the
economy if we go through it so
interest rates right now 5.7
which means you would have bought a
house eight months ago your rates would
have been three percent two and a half
percent right now it's 5.7 percent
here's what people don't realize
if you go back from today
let's just say go all the way back to
1970.
do you know from 2008
prior from 2008 and prior like
to 2008 do you know the interest rates
have never been at 5.7 percent it's
always about 5.7
let me say this one more time from 08
and prior to 70 rates have always been
six and a half seven and a half eight
and a half nine and a half
in 181 under carter was at 18 and a half
percent okay but that was pretty bad now
let's go worst case scenario let's go
best case scenario and you decide where
you want to manage your level of risk
tolerance worst case scenario we're
going to hit 19 in interest rates what's
the likelihood of that happening less
than five percent okay
but that's 19 that's worst case what's
the best case scenario we end up around
seven seven and a half and we stayed
there for a few years okay we go to
seven seven and a half maybe we go up
and hit ten points which we probably
will and then we come back down and
level off around seven to eight percent
which is fine if we stay at seven to
eight percent for a decade give or take
a decade and we're kind of like i got a
good rate what rate did you get seven
point one percent fine
but now we're going back to being
fiscally responsible instead of keeping
these interest rates at zero and you're
getting loans at two and a half percent
which is all fake money and it's not the
real way of doing it so yes we're in
recession but
i'm almost
i'm almost leaning towards the
administration doing nothing now the
only thing i would recommend if the
administration wanted to do something
like this who who does the current
administration need the most today well
um a story came out talking about the
fact that companies now are rescinding
offers how often do you even read an
article like that that means
twitter gave you a job offer for a
hundred grand with fifty thousand
dollars in bonuses with 401k all this
stuff
you get started on the 19th
and they say to you a week later after
you put in your two week notice we're
rescinding that java
okay
zuckerberg is wanting to fire people
he's doing the right thing tesla's
firing people a bunch of companies are
letting people go and that's gonna be
taking place now
if that happens and a lot of people lose
their jobs economy is gonna take a hit
crime's going to go up a lot of scary
things could happen if economy that's
that gap gets that bad the one thing
biden and their administration could
potentially do is
and dave you tell me what you think
about this what if they said
hey you got these five employees you
could hire this year at 50 grand or pop
let's just pick the number 50 you pop
five times 50. if you hire five
employees you give them a job mr
employer mr small business owner which
is 49 of america 49 of all the jobs are
small business owners
um if you give those five people fifty
thousand dollar your jobs we'll give you
tax credit on half of it which means
what i mean because i hire five people
overnight
that's what i would do yeah so now small
business owners are like listen john
come on 50k 25 000 tax credit come on so
that way
the employer wins the employee wins and
the administration wins those are the
types of things that the administration
can do not the ppp loan not free money
not at ubi no let's kind of work
put it on me put it on the employee put
it on the government let's work together
the next two three years because it's
going to get ugly so i can hear loudly
through the pipes of the internet all of
the people watching this going patrick
you just made sense there but the
problem is that the democrats are in
charge and that there is basically a
controlled demolition of our economy one
of the things that i talk about on the
show a lot is i try not to judge
people's motives but it seems almost
impossible for me to believe that this
is not intentional that the inflation
stuff is not intentional the printing of
money is not intentional all the people
everything that they have done has been
designed specific everything with energy
specifically designed to destroy the
economy so of course what you just said
there makes sense like anything
literally anything some tax relief for
people fine but they won't do any of it
because it is by design do you do you
buy that theory oh let's play let's play
that part let's let's buy this
i hope it is great do it by design do it
but i'm totally okay with you doing it
by design here's why
because
they think majority of the american
people are dummies and they're not
let's not let's not expect that
everybody's brilliant no we're naive if
we think that
let's let's say 40 of people are not
going to pay attention to anything and
they're going to fall for that you're
right it's the rich man's fault let's
tax the billionaires it's not going to
solve anything right but if that's their
card it'll backfire why let's unpack
that
so
go with
defund the police what a great marketing
campaign
and the republicans were so worried look
at these i can't believe they're saying
this let them say it
because their own people are going to
turn against them
six months later the hell are you
talking about defunded police democrats
are saying it to democrats i voted for
you i don't want you to defund the
police
well we never said it it was really the
republicans no no you said it you said
this this is not a good idea so watch
this this whole concept where you know
many people on the left were saying you
companies corporations you should let
people work from home or really yes
you should let people work from home no
problem who said that
liberal governors from left-leaning
states okay
they said that sounded like a very good
idea like you're supporting so many
people on your own site no no here's
what you did when you said you should be
able to let them work from home the
people said oh so you need to tell me i
can work for ibm and work from home yes
nope around new york i'm moving to
florida and i'll work from
new york lost
21 billion dollars of tax revenue last
year so even though dave they're doing
it intentionally if they are
majority of america is going to fall for
the tactic tactics and they're going to
say yeah i'm kind of not with you i'm
stepping away from you and they'll flip
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell